Al the reason why Islam said what he
said
regarding because you can see what what
they inite in the youth imagine the
youth adopting these ideas and I haven't
even SC the surface of Al and his
speechi and others and their
representatives in the west from the
leaders ofan
whether or other than
them it is no wonder that the scholars
they warn against them generation after
generation
andl he said in Al volume
two
he said it is
W to punish whomsoever ascribes himself
to or defends
them or Praises
them or venerates their
books or is known to Aid them and
support
them or that he
hates speak
against
them or that he makes excuses for them
rather it is
obligatory to punish
whomsoever knows the condition
of but he does not assist in standing
against them for indeed standing against
them is from the
most obligatory of
obligations
and as has been mentioned
by he said that whomsoever the one who
sits
with
is worse against us or more severe upon
us than
themselves and
sufan he said that
whosoever accompanies and walks with
the who with us he's
a now people may find some of these
speech
strong and what we are referring to here
is not your average Army
J unlearned person who falls into B yes
he is upon B there's no doubt what we
are referring to here is the callers to
B those who stand up and defend the
ideas and the ideologies of innovation
and misguidance from the from the from
the
mat from the
various from the various Sufi
orders from the people
of from the
philosophers from
the and the
ra from
likewise the Muslim and the DI and other
than
them that we say regarding these types
of
individuals that yes we warn against
them before in fact I go on to the next
question I just want to make a
comment as an
example because through this example and
through the r and
reputation of the likes of these
individuals we actually learned quite a
lot about about the salafi manage
because reading the
K of R reading the books and the
writings in reputation a salafi can
actually equip
himself with a lot of knowledge that
will protect him and protect his family
and protect his
companions so from the people that we
find in this time who has gained
notoriety not because he has any
knowledge because he's a Jah he's an
ignoramus he's he's ignorant of the AK
he's of the manh he's ignorant of the
Sunnah he's ignorant of the scholars
he's ignorant of what the meaning of t
and he hasn't got the first
clue about what will bring about the
benefit in the umah but he
belittles and the
salais him and those who are like him so
they will and his name is uh
Daniel so he calls the
Salis that's the first thing that that
he does so he wants to detach you he
wants the people to think that these
people are not people of Sunnah they're
just some cult or some kind of like
marginalized group called
M and he does this in his attempt to
ascribe the salais to one of the major
scholars ofah in this time and then he
is of course the renowned IM scholar of
Hadith from the great scholars in his
'90s alive today praised by
almost every scholar of the
era IM Alani called him the
IM called him the Imani called him
the that he is the carrier of the banner
of in this
time called him an IM of the
Sunnah said you shouldn't ask me about
him rather you should ask him about me
just like when they went to Imam Ahmed
and they asked him about Muhammad
B he said rather it is him that should
be asked about me rather than the other
way around or it might have been is bin
Rah the doubt is from me but regardless
the scholars have praised him and
they've spoken well of
she right up until this day and he is in
his
90s so this Jew has taken it upon
himself to demean and
revile the salais and anyone who praises
RAB so if you were to sayab is an and I
take
from and I read his books just like I
read the books of other Scholars and his
writings and I read his reputations and
his fwa just like I do
withed he's a scholar from the and he's
from the most excellent of them but
Daniel here msk uses the term to
intimidate bully and frighten the people
from the salafi
da so a person now when he says oh he
wants you to be
defensive because he doesn't want the
people to ascribe themselves to she RAB
so maybe they'll flee from the writings
and from the manage of these great
Scholars and this is not something new
and I mentioned it previously that the
rafida and the various Sufi
orders that they let
laed
asab which is intended as a derogatory
term for the ones who read study benefit
from The Works of a and of Islam
muhammadin Abdul wahab and this method
of revilement and belittlement is the
way
of in every age for this reason the two
imams of the early
salaf in their tremendous work
that they mention that the
distinguishing sign of the people
of is their reviling of the people of
narrations and they mentioned the terms
employed by to frighten the people away
from because that's the intent
here that's the intent to scare the
people away if I give them this
derogatory term or
title that this will keep the people
away from listening to she or listening
to the salais or listening to Muhammad
bin Abdul wahab and other than them so
Abu and Abu Zur in the thir Century in
their
book that they
mention and
as
uh other Scholars have narrated from
them such as IM and others that they say
that the distinguishing signs of the Zan
of the Heretics is that they
label the worthless ones and they seek
to invalidate the narrations look the
intent is
what to invalidate the narrations so
they
call the worthless ones
the the distinguishing sign of the J is
that they
label with the
term those who resemble Allah to the
creation so this is not anything new I
mean Abu Zur died in 264 abim in 277
these are from the era of IM
Ahmed so you find this revilement and
the way of in opposing theth of the
Prophet Sall wasallam to oppose the
prophetic narrations is not to Target
the narrations themselves so you won't
find the likes of this Jew saying don't
take from BK don't take the Hadith in
bukari don't follow the Hadith of the
Prophet sallam you can't you know he's
not as bold to say that so what do they
do
instead they target the
scholars they target the carriers of the
and
the of the messenger of allaham just
like
said distinguishing sign of is there
reviling and for this
reason and this is a point to note died
in 240 after the
hij and I'll tell you why it's important
to note this he said if you see a man
loving the likes of who died in 143 ABD
rmann Mah who died in 198 Ahmed who died
in 241 isin Rah who died in
238 and he mentioned a group of others
know that he is upon the Sunnah if you
see a man loving and all of these
Scholars know that he is upon the Sunnah
and whoever opposes them know that he's
an
innovator collected
by now the point is here look did not
say if you find a man rejecting the
Hadith of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he didn't say that he said if
you see a man loving or hating or
opposing if you find him loving and then
you name these great Scholars he's a
person of Sunnah if you find a person
opposing them no he's an innovator and
reviling the scholars of
Hadith is a sign of
zand it is a sign of heresy it is a sign
of hypocrisy in a person Ahmed
Hass he said to IM Ahmed he said abdah
he said to IM
Ahmed he said that the scholars of
Hadith were mentioned Tob
in
meca so he said
meaning said
theith are a wicked people so Imam Ahmed
heard this and he stood up and he
started brushing off his
th while saying zind z z up until he
entered his
home so here who is the attack leveled
at it is leveled against the carriers of
the Hadith of Allah's messenger
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam because the scholars they
understood like
like
likeed like Abu Z abui the
r they understood that the intent of
attacking the scholars of Hadith andah
and Sala the intent is the narration of
the Prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
himself but you don't have the courage
to say
it so this is their
way so then he writes this uh diet
tribe this uh Jew that is dated the 2nd
of May
2023 when I saw
it uh it had already been seen by nearly
27,000 people this cam against the
salais so he writes this thing by that
date which is I don't know when it was
maybe a few weeks
ago or a few months ago even that this
is it was viewed by nearly 30,000 people
let's say 27 I don't know how many by
now look at how quickly B and the ideas
of B they spread so this is what he said
in his tweet and I'll give it sentence
by sentence or paragraph by paragraph he
said because the M are run this is word
for word because M are run by state
intelligence agencies for propaganda
purposes they are only concerned with
politics and have reduced the entire
religion of Islam to politics end of
quote so this individual believes that
the salafi scholars the students of
knowledge the callers to salafia whom he
calls madis
are run by state
intelligence
agencies we know as he well knows that
this is a great lie
against and it is something impossible
to
prove it is no difference to accusing a
Muslim who prays
fasts and he shows outward
piety it is accusing him of being a
maafi
based only on his hatred for other
Muslims imagine if you see a Muslim you
see from impiety he prays he fasts he
practices the Sunnah but then you accuse
him of being a
maafi how do you prove such a
thing so seeks to belittle and revile
the salais and accuse them
falsely and Allah will call him to
account and may Allah give him what he
deserves he further claims that these
so-call are only con concerned with
politics that's what he said they are
only concerned with politics and they
have reduced the entire religion of
Islam to
politics this is where you have to
question the sanity of this
ignoramus or does he actually think that
Muslims will read that and actually not
investigate does he not know in fact the
whole of the umah I'm sure knows that
the salais are at the Forefront of
calling the people to toed of Allah and
warning from
sh they call to
the the salais warn against they call to
the Sunnah and they warn against B they
call to the manage and the methodology
of the salaf and they warn from straying
against straying from their path just
look at the books that the salafi mash
and the salafi scholars and the salafi
students of knowledge that they teach in
every part of the
worlded the found the foundations of the
Creed of IM ahed who died in
241 of
imar another book of and man who died in
329 of
Islam of Muhammad abdah and so on and so
forth this is what the Sal teach the
Sala teach the people the regulations of
worship through books such
as the salais teach the books of T
Hadith Arabic language and so on
so this
Daniel then he's a slanderer a a scandal
mongerer he just wants to make and make
and belittle the people of Sunnah and to
malign
them this is what he intends with the
people ofah Hadith and salaf it is clear
to anyone that this individual has never
studied the books of AA and methodology
of the salaf for him to make some of the
comments that he's made he has never
studied the books of AA and this is
further confirmed by the fact by the
fact that he identifies
himself as a diandi with the deviated
Indian sect of
diand that only came about in the
1850s so he identifies himself with a
sect that is less than 200 years old
that has been refuted by the scholars of
Sunnah and Hadith of India and outside
of India so it is no wonder that if
you're going to identify yourself with a
SE that is
innovated and came about in the 1850s no
wonder you don't know the first thing
abouted ofar or Al or the statements
of or the books of Hadith andah and Sala
or the books of the great Scholars such
as andu of the 8th Century he doesn't
have a foggiest of what those books are
talking about how does this ignoramus
come to the conclusion that the salais
have reduced the religion to politics
when it is the salais who are constantly
advising the Muslims to stop talking
about the rulers and leave politics to
the scholars but rather focus on
learning and worship and purification
from false practices superstitions and
innovations that we are to cultivate
ourselves and our families and the Next
Generation upon the true Creed the true
AA and true IM the pure Sunnah and upon
righteous deeds and following the
messenger of Allah wasallam this is the
man
of are we to believe that this Shan
doesn't know that this is the dawa of
the salafi scholars such asani and and
and and fan and and so
on doesn't he know that this is our da
in the
west he's a kadab because he knows full
well
he knows our salafi marakis and
mid in America in Canada in Britain
across Europe in the Middle East in the
Indian subcontinent he knows so he
invents these lies as I said at the
beginning to cause the people to flee
from the truth that they have reduced
the whole of the religion to
politics then he says first the M teach
that the most important a issue is the
difference between
and the M claim that anyone who verbally
criticizes liberal government Poli
policies is a deviant
apostate who must be
surveilled
imprisoned or
killed by contrast he said the
traditional Sunni works and AA do not
make such claim claims moreover while
such Works reject
kism they do not focus on it as a key
issue end of his words our response
another lie
another where have the salafis
taught ever that the most important AA
issue is the difference between and the
bring a quote where a salafy
scholar or because his focus is
upon may Allah preserve him bring us a
quote where any of the salfi scholars
have said that the most important issue
is the difference
between and
thean bring your proof If you are
truthful the Sal the Sal da calls to
above all else you know that and I know
that and everyone knows that that's why
they criticize us you're always talking
about toed because we call to toed Above
All Else it doesn't mean it is the only
thing but above everything to comes
first and I'm sure that this untruthful
fabricator knows this but he has managed
to deceive some of the people but just
to put the issue to
rest let's read from she RAB because RAB
is the target of his attack for I don't
know for whatever reason but but she RAB
has been attack of many
innovators over his
lifespan that's why the scholars
defended him against the attacks but
anyway let's read
from from his tremendous
work this is the book of page number 43
the methodology of the prophets in
calling to Allah in that is wisdom and
intelligence so this is the words of so
said concerning the da of the he said
Allah the most high said regarding the
messengers who were the firmest in
resolve and the firmest in deter ation
May Allah's peace and blessings be upon
all of them Allah said regarding
them that Allah has ordained for you of
religion that which we which he ordained
upon and that which we have revealed
upon you oh Muhammad and that which we
enjoined upon ibraim and M and Isa to
establish their religion and not be
divided therein so sheab comments upon
these upon these words of Allah by
saying this was the call of all of The
Messengers and at the head of them are
those firmest in resolve and
determination that have been mentioned
in this Ayah the prophets of Allah who
numbered
124,000 proceeded upon a single
methodology in their dawa and they be
began from a singular starting point
which
wased the call to the worship of Allah
alone this was the greatest Affair and
the greatest Foundation which They
Carried to the whole of mankind
throughout the ages despite their
various societies lands and time
periods then he said this proves that
this is the single path that is
obligatory to following calling the
people to Allah it is the way laid down
by Allah prescribed for His prophets and
his true and sincere followers it is not
permissible to alter that way or to
change it nor to turn away from it end
of the words
ofid don't forget what the Shan
said he
said to
repeat the M teach that the most
important a issue is the difference
between and
the this is what said this is what you
ascribe to whom you call disparagingly
the
M this one paragraph exposes the
Fabrications of against this Noble
scholar and the salafi
da hates the fact that the salais and
their Scholars prohibit speaking out
openly and demonstrating publicly
against the tyrannical Muslim rulers he
hates it so therefore anything just like
say anything that gets in the way of
your politics
no matter who it is a great
scholar it doesn't matter whoever stands
in your world view of what is right and
wrong
politically he's going to get attacked
so therefore
shab gets attacked by you have mercy
upon your horns oh
goat don't worry about the mountain if
you're going to bang your head against
the mountain you're going to break your
horns you
goat all right so worry about yourself
don't worry
about is the mountain that you're trying
to hit your head against have mercy upon
your
head so the reader can
understand that the salais of course
they don't refute and they don't
publicly demonstrate and they don't
speak against the Muslim rulers publicly
Our advice to the Muslim rulers is in
private or by writing to them and if it
is said if something is said by the
scholars then it is said in a way that
is that this is the advice like a
scholar would say this is my advice to
the umah and to the rulers and to their
Scholars and to their to their academics
and to their notables this is my advice
to them the scholars will say that and
that encompasses the rulers also and
there's no harm in that and you find
that from she and and
others but anyway in case you're in any
doubt that you're confused or anyone is
confused any listener that listens to
this afterwards he confused and he says
well why can't we speak against the
rulers the position
of towards the tyrannical Wicked rulers
is very clear and very apparent and
we'll mention it from aith perspective
because we are so either you're going to
accept the Hadith or you're going to
reject the Hadith then we'll add to that
some of the statements of the scholars
and you know you could write a volume in
this but obviously time doesn't permit
us this evening to go through numerous
narration after narration that would
take till fud possibly and even
longer Muslim reported in his
from that Salin
ya asked the messenger of
Allah Allah oh prophet of Allah what do
we do if we have rulers over us who
demand their rights yet they withhold
our rights the prophet said listen to
them and Obey them regardless upon them
is their burden and upon you will be
your burden end of
Hadith did he say go and speak out
against them go and March in the streets
against them gather
together start a
podcast he said listen to them and Obey
them Imam Ahmed IU H because we are
salafi and we follow the salaf you're
the aundi so you're going to follow the
abund
so us to ours and you to yours and we'll
see who's right and who's
wrong the of the and the man of the
salaf or the mother of thean from 1850
India we'll
see who's right and who's wrong so our
Sal we quoted the Hadith and we'll come
back to Future Hadith but here's a
Hadith or here's a narration from Imam
ahed as is recorded
by the book that is a compendium an
encyclopedia of the where in
immed said it is not permissible for
anyone amongst the people to fight the
ruler nor rise up against him and
whosoever whomsoever does that is an
innovator he's a upon other than the
Sunnah and upon other than the straight
path end of the words of IM
Ahmed reported in
and
from that Allah's messenger sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said listen listen to
the ruler and Obey him when it is hard
for you and when it is easy for you
whether you are pleased or whether you
are displeased and when others are given
preference over you and even when they
consume your wealth and they beat you in
your back end of the Hadith declared
sah and narration is of course authentic
as we have
mentioned said in volume 28 page
179 he said being patient with the
tyranny of the rulers is a fundamental
principle is an from the fundamentals
of end of the quote of the messenger of
Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam made it
explicitly clear that it is forbidden to
speak openly against the Muslim ruler
but rather to advise him in private
regardless of his tyranny IM Ahmed
reported in Al and
also and the narration is and others
have mentioned the prophet said
whomsoever wishes to advise the ruler
let him not do so
openly let him not do so
openly rather he should take him by his
hand take him into seclusion and then
advise him if he accepts that from him
it is in his favor and if he does not
then the advisor has fulfilled his
duty end of the quote from Allah's
messenger sallallahu alaihi wasam
so these few narrations show how foolish
and
ignorant the statement of this je
is that while he says yes such Works do
reject they do not focus on it as a key
AA issue so what are these
then this is not the AKA of IM Ahmed
this is not the AA of this is not the AA
of and the command of Allah that is not
your they don't focus it as a key issue
but just in case you're
confused
further so that you are left in no doubt
about the position and the fact that
refuting
the and opposing them is a matter of
AA and they don't focus on it as a key
he's trying to divert like basically
speak against the rulers do what you
want against the rulers because it's not
really a key issue
right not really key whatever that means
in his
head
Imam who died in
628 stated
in he said
they have
agreed that hearing and obeying the
ruler is obligatory and they have
agreed that whomsoever gains authority
of the Affairs of the people of a
country whether it was with their
pleasure or by seizing power with Brute
Force whether the rulers are Pious or
tyrannical then it is then they are not
to be rebelled against with the swords
regardless of whether the leaders are
oppressive or just end of the quote ofan
Ali let's move
on
Islam Abu
the great IM who died in the year 449
after the he said in
his page 32 he
said do not hold that it is permissible
to reev to revolt against them the
rulers even if they see them abandoning
Justice that's what he talks about
social justice that these rulers they're
abandoning Justice he says even if they
abandon Justice and replacing it with
tyranny and injury it is not permissible
to revolt against them then he ended his
treaties with these sentences that I
have affirmed in this chapter were the
were
the of all of them the scholars of none
of them differed regarding it with each
other rather they agreed by by
consensus with it all end of the quote
of
imuni let's take from abass because they
like
to you know say that we're so take from
your died
324 he said in
[Music]
his page
168 number
45 he
said have agreed upon hearing and
obeying the rulers of the Muslims and
whomsoever gains authority over the
people whether with their pleasure or by
overpowering them then obedience is
given to them whether they are righteous
or sinful it is not allowed to revolt
against them regardless if they are
tyrannical or just end of the words of
Imam Abul
Hassan
finally just to seal it
the two imams Abu
Zur died 264 Abu Haim died
277 stated the they said we reach the
scholars of all of the townships of the
hijaz Iraq sham
Yemen and from their beliefs was we do
not hold it permissible to rebel against
the rulers or to fight in times of FNA
we hear and obey Those whom Allah has
placed in authority over us we do not
remove the hand of obedience we follow
the Sunnah and the JAMA we oppose
opposition differing and
splitting this is
salaf this is Sala you don't like it
then you are the one who is deviated we
don't look at the world the world view
is not taken from your small
mind rather the is rooted in these
narrations of
the of the more of the Sal so we're
going to listen to
you then he
said in the next part of his tweet M
promote the study of as a way to promote
secularism end of
quote I mean how do you respond okay so
we study and teach the works of a and
man of
ahmedani Abu ma Muslim
B
alar abdah and so on because we want to
promote promote
secularism so we study all of them
because we want to promote and push
secularism and you
innovator and you you withhold from
reading and studying these works because
you want to promote and uphold the
belief of the
Muslims so we teach these books to teach
secularism and promote it so you don't
teach them because you want to establish
Islam you can't say much more on that
brainless
point then continues M hold that Muslims
should devote themselves exclusively to
the study of technical AA issues
remember take a person upon his words he
said they devote themselves exclusive
exclusively then he previously he said
all we talk about is
politics everything is politics now we
exclusively devote ourselves to the
study of technical issues
EG what is the
precise meaning
of teach that Muslims must not work for
sh in state and Society until we are all
agreed upon these
technical
issues assume that this will take a long
undefined period possibly forever during
this period Muslims should passively
allow governments to implement liberal
secularizing policies which remove Islam
Islam from State and
Society notice that while
the pretend that they are concerned with
AA have a bizarre unprecedented
understanding of AA for the essence of
proper AKA is refraining from verbally
criticizing liberal government policies
and passively cooperating in the removal
of religion from from State and
Society rather
than reducing Islam to politics and
liberal
political propaganda M should study
genuine
genuine until they do so they should be
regarded as who are at war with end of
quote that's
rich so this ignoramus this jahil
invents positions in his mind then
ascribes them to the salais
toah and then he expects the people
people to believe him for the record
the do not say that one should
exclusively devote himself to the study
of technical AA issues no salafy scholar
has ever said
that yeah find me yourself prove your
point bring me a primary source any
salafi scholar in the history of dawa
Sala he said that they should
exclusively devote themselves to the
study of technical AA
issues rather let me give him a lesson
the salais Begin by studying toed and
the pillars of IM belief in Allah belief
in the Angels belief in his books his
Messengers The Last Day the
precre the salae worships Allah alone
establishes the prayer pays the zaka
fasts the month of Ramadan and strives
to perform Hajj he is good to his
parents treats them with kindness he
feeds the poor he enjoins the good he
prohibits the evil in accordance to his
knowledge and ability he studies the
book of Allah understands its meaning by
reading the well-known books of T the
salais called to the called to rectify
the um through the prophetic methodology
of purification Tasia and cultivation
I hope that enlightens
this of course would think that the
precise meaning of Allah's Ascension
over the throne is from the technical
issues of AA Allah being over the throne
is not from the fine detailed technical
issues of AA because he's an ignorant
follower of the
dundis he wouldn't know that because he
said himself about himself he said I am
a complete fan of that
movement and I've had multiple diandi
teachers I'm a fanboy no doubt about it
end of quote of so no one says that
I'm exaggerating or adding so it's no
wonder my brothers and sisters that he
hasn't the foggiest idea of the
importance of
Allah's Allah's Ascension over the
throne it's no wonder because he's a
diandi
let me just give you one
fatwa from the DI so you understand the
of the
diandi so this is from
dar.com
question number
496 answer number
496 published 20th of July
2008 just in case people say you just
made that
up
the question that they are
posed the scholars
of it's signed at the end asalam alaykum
my wife want to stay with Hindu woman
sorry let me correct that my wife want
to stay with Hindu
man to whom she loves it is question of
IM and also of
ISAT one to ask is there any kind of Dua
or WIA to bring wife back home without
giving her to eat or drink anything and
keep her in
control that's the deep and meaningful
question put
to so gives a deep and meaningful
answer they
say after Isa Salah take 11 grains of
black pepper
and recite y y
1,100
times with dud 11 times before and after
while thinking your wife to love
you having it done blow on the black
peppers and put them in burning fire and
pray to Allah do this at least for 40
days
Allah knows
best you couldn't make this stuff
up you don't have
to all
right the dandis also believe in other
you know he's got the audacity to speak
about the AKA of the salais while
calling himself a fanboy of this
stuff so
on one of the you know when you there's
another website that is called inter
islam.org so on inter islam.org we have
the life and miracles of hazzat
mus with a forward from Haz molana YF
mahalah principal
of so on and so forth Barry UK and so on
Barry UK senior khif okay of HZ molana
Muhammad Zakaria
sa some fuk now this is the quote and I
won't add and I won't take away some
fuk give Glad Tidings of hazzat becoming
great a great Pious Saint even before
his birth for instance One MA one who is
lost in Divine
meditation by the name of
nimia who used to stay naked because his
clothes would burn
away used to come to Tad kwar from
Baruch on one occasion hz's grandmother
who was inclined to this ma the one lost
in Divine meditation she was inclined to
him requested him that he make Dua that
Allah tala I'm reading exactly is Allah
tala Grant him grant them a son the Maj
commented what will you do with a
son then he
pointing towards az's mother who was
still in her
childhood and said this girl will bear
such a son who will be a great and Pious
Saint thereafter he presented the
household with a handkerchief and a ring
and he ordered to be given to that
child by Chance the local person at
whose house the Maj was staying at found
out about this favor so out of jealousy
and envy he stole the handkerchief and
ring hazrat's mother grandmother went
and informed the Maj Sab regarding the
theft on hearing this the maub Saab
commented Whoever has stolen these
things his house will be
destroyed hence three sons of that
person died after realizing the outcome
of the mistake the person presented
himself with the handkerchief and the
ring and apologized to the Maj who said
in Return there's no need for this now
so this naked guy end of quot so this
naked
PAB travels from City he can't wear
clothes because as soon as he puts on
clothes they burn off his body right so
they burn away so he's walking around
naked so this elderly woman sees him
naked and she's inclined towards him
meaning towards his piety not towards
his nakedness necessarily towards his
piety and she wants a a
child so she requests from him to grant
them a son so instead he points to the
young girl she's a little girl she said
she will have a son and he will be a
great Pious Saint fortune
telling from a naked
man who walks around from Village to
Village this is your dianda and you know
you could carry on like this and you
know with with this type of nonsense all
day and night so the question that
arises because he's saying that you know
you just focus upon Allah being over the
and you know this is a technical a issue
so let's give this a quick
lesson this Fanboy of the
deobandis IM Abu
jaur who died in
321 because they say Abu ja is Hani the
diis they say he's a Hani scholar he is
a Hani
scholar but he said in his a about this
technical issue that you find so
difficult to get your head around so he
said in point number 50 and 51 in his
IM he Allah has no need of the
throne or whatever is beneath it Allah
encompasses everything and is above
it Allah encompasses everything and he
is above it above the throne and he has
made his creation incapable of
encompassing is that too difficult for
him
is a technical issue Allah said it in
the
Quran the most merciful has ascended
over his throne IM where's the technical
issue that exclusively you have to focus
upon these exclusively you know the
language that they
use said there appears in some of the
books of speculative
theology such as the diis and others he
means where they say it is not allowed
to ascribe to Allah with being in a
particular direction they reject the
highness of Allah and that he is above
thinking that affirming this direction
for Allah necessitates placing limits
upon him but this is not the case
because we know that above the throne
there is nothing from the creation there
is none over it except Allah and there
is absolutely nothing of his creation
that encompasses or confines him so we
say Allah is in the direction of above
because Allah's messenger sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said to the slave girl
Ain Allah where is
Allah Allah's messenger sallallah
wasallam said to the slave girl where is
Allah the term where a Allah
a is seeking to know the place so she
replied above the
sky so she affirmed that Allah is above
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam confirmed that and he said free
her for she is a believer theith in sah
Muslim of Muth number 33 so the
direction affirm for Allah is not
lowly highness for Allah is affirmed by
the fitra the innate nature sound
intellect and the revealed text the
affirmation of direction for Allah is
not encompassment of him because of the
fact that his foot stol his kury extends
over the heavens and the Earth and it is
the place of his two feet as is affirmed
in some AAR so how can anything from his
creation confine confine him so he is in
the direction of above without any
confinement and it is not per permitted
to say there is something that confines
him or encompasses him and we
say there is over
the nothing besides Allah the most
perfect free of all
imperfections
this is what we
believe and that is
from take his you like to quote him when
he suits
you now quote him in this is now
opposing is he a for speaking
about the highness of Allah and this is
from the
ma to prove this point we have another
narration wherein Allah's messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said when
Allah completed the completed the
creation he wrote in his book that is
with him above
the above Allah wrote in his book that
is where with
him above the throne and he said my
Mercy has prevailed over my anger the
Hadith in bukari and
Muslim so the Sunni the salafi the
person of Hadith believes with certainty
that Allah is is over the throne
furthermore the throne is above the
water which is above the foot stol which
is above the seven
Heavens which are above the Earth Allah
is above all of this furthermore this
ignorant upstart self-confessed diandi
Fanboy wants Muslims to participate in
some sort of backlash against the
governments of Muslim countries because
according to him the salais hold that
Muslims should passively allow
governments to implement liberal
secularizing policies he and his likes
want to incite the Muslims into open
criticism against the rulers using
social media platforms podcasts accusing
the copies accusing accusing she RAB and
the of Sala of being bootlickers that's
the actual term that they use and they
use it over and over again to get it
into the minds of the people don't
follow
these these people of who follow the M
of the Sala so they invent these terms
bootlickers M
wahabis Saudi
salafis this is the type of terms that
they use why because they want to incite
the people upon their manh they want the
people to go out and demonstrate they
want the people to go out and speak
against the
rulers so in this he agrees with all of
his compatriots from Muslim and the so
they may differ in their which they do
in their thinking in their ideologies in
their afar in their fopa they differ
from each
other but in this they agree they agree
upon this criticism and attack upon the
rulers in this you find that the likes
of yan and their ilk that they always
promote this anti Saudi Arabia anti-
Gulf countries anti-i rulers
anti you know rulers of Emirates or
other countries
they keep pushing this idea into the
minds of the people speak against them
speak against them speak against the
rulers they all are united upon
this whilst they sit in the comfort of
their homes misguided and misguiding
others the messenger of Allah sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said as we have stated
before if one of you sees something from
the ruler that he hates let him not
publicize it that's what
said so what do they do publicize it and
they say that they are and we
are he said count them what did he say
he said count them these
M salais count them
amongst and they are at war
with yet you are the one denying the
narrations you are the one denying the
AAR of the salaf Prophet Salli wasallam
said rather you should take the ruler by
his hand into to seclusion and advise
him
privately because these are the of and
and and they know the of The Da he said
if you cannot take the ruler by his hand
into seclusion write to him privately
because the same effect is achieved if
he takes it alhamdulillah if he refuses
then you have fulfilled your
duty this is how the salais deal with
these types of Affairs
that's how we deal with it do we speak
about the sins that occur in the Muslim
lands of course we
do and we say to the people stop sinning
stop listening to
music what do you think the scholars do
in Saudi Arabia what the youth don't
listen to music they don't watch movies
of course they do so what do the
scholars say stop listening to music
stop dealing in
ribba stop gambling stop watching
pornography stop going to
movies
that's what the scholars
do the scholars speak about the pain and
suffering that the Muslim umah is facing
whether it be the people of
Palestine or the people of
Kashmir or the people in other countries
that are suffering at the hands of the
kufar and the RAF and other than them
they make Dua for
them and they advise the umah the rulers
and the ruled to adhere to the kab and
the Sunnah to follow the Sharia
that was sent to Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam so this in
reality is
the
Jew enmity
of he is a hater of the man
of he is an opposer of the path of the
early Sal him and whomsoever agrees with
him and there is no two ways there's no
like you know I'll dip my foot into the
the some of the lectures of this
je no we don't you don't need anything
from and the one who defends him is
either an ignoramus or he is like him
one or the other if he is an ignoramus
we teach
him if he's like him you are abandoned
just like he is abandoned and those who
are similar to him
abandoned so he says about the salais
they should be regarded as at war with
so all of this shows that we are
with
a rather the opposite of that is true so
do not be deceived by these charlatans
who ascribe themselves to the Sunnah of
our Noble Prophet
s
I know I've gone plenty over but uh I
think it had to be said for the
record set the record straight and speak
the truth and don't fear the blame of
the
blamers